what is going on everybody and welcome
to an update to the Python plays Grand
Theft Auto series also sort of an
addition to the object detection
tutorials that we've been covering so a
prerequisite basically for this the next
few videos is going to be the object
detection API with tensorflow so I just
released a tutorial series on that so if
you need to you can go to Python
programming that you should be able to
just search for object and you'll find
the tensorflow object detection api
tutorial series here you probably want
to get at least through their like one
in two after at part 3 we start tracking
custom objects which is super cool but
we're not going to be doing any custom
objects in this series so or this little
batch of videos anyways so really you
just need to do part one in two probably
anyway that's it for that and let's go
ahead and get into it so what I'm going
to be starting with here is the that
basically like the ipython notebook
tutorial code I've output that I just
went you know file save as vehicle
detector dot PI and that just gives me
it in a Python script so I can work
there Excel really like your notebook
but if you want to say a notebook you
can do that too so the first things that
we're gonna do is we're gonna just kind
of clean this up a little bit so we're
going to be using basically since we're
gonna be playing Grand Theft Auto we're
gonna be grabbing the screen via grand
theft or via our crab screen function
that we wrote for the Python play series
and we're not going to be using
matplotlib at all so what we can do is
is just get rid of the matte plot let
import we don't need to do this magic
stuff whoops and then we can also like
clean up the lines stuff like that we do
need these things if you don't have the
model already download it you should
leave this in and run it at least once I
suppose but if you followed my
instructions and you follow the
tutorials leading up to this you've
already had that model so you can just
download that
I'm just gonna keep cleaning up a little
bit some helper code and then in the
detection we don't really need to detect
any of this stuff so we can remove the
images there and the image size we
weren't really worried about that and
then down here I'm just gonna remove
this plot stuff and that should be good
enough just kind of gonna clean things
up slightly so so our goal here is to
just get this working in Grand Theft
Auto so can we just use the object
detection API in Grand Theft Auto to
detect objects because so far up to this
point I've shown how to do it on images
I've shown how to do it by your webcam
and now I'm gonna show you guys how we
can do it in a game you don't have to
have Grand Theft Auto for this but the
more realistic the game the better or
you can just I suppose just watch and
follow along but you don't have to use
grand theft auto anything that's fairly
realistic should work so what we're
going to do to grab the screen is to use
grab screen from the Python or PI GTA 5
on github so that's just github.com
slash Santa / PI GTA 5 I'll try to
remember to put a link in description if
I forget somebody can remind me
otherwise you can just go to github back
on the URL I just said so go ahead go
there get grab screen save it you can
just go to raw and click save as and
then save that in the working directory
and once you have that we can go up to
the very top and we're gonna go from
grab screen import grab underscore
screen and then we're gonna also import
cv2 now what we're gonna do is come down
into this kind of like main this is like
the main block of code basically that
starts the session runs the graph and
then iterates through the images
basically we're actually prints the
graph starts the session anyways
rather than for image and blah blah blah
we're actually just gonna wow true this
because we're just we just want to keep
going forever and then rather than image
equals you know open the image path and
then
converting it to image numpy we're
actually just gonna basically do this
we're just going to say we can say
screen equals CV to resize and then
we're gonna say Rab underscore spleen
and then we'll just we'll say the region
and we're just going to hard-code this
for me that's gonna be 0 40 and I'll
explain this in a moment
78745 and then we're just gonna resize
that to be about 800 by 450 just so it's
not huge at least on my GPU I actually
could pass through this full screen and
wouldn't run into memory issues but
basically the smaller we can get away
with this the faster it's going to run
because this screen here is what we're
actually going to be running the object
detection against and so the bigger
basically the way the object detection
works anything with like the bounding
boxes works is it segments out like
frames or not frames like squares on the
image so you've got this you know image
like this and then it goes like little
squares and we'll actually well it
depends on which one you're using but
probably it starts with like maybe
bigger squares and it starts shifting
them down basically but or will start
with little and go bigger but anyways it
just let's say it just does some boxes
just box and then shift shift shift
shift shift and each time it's trying to
detect is this object in this box and
then it just keeps kind of shrinking
that box until it's like not we don't
see that object anymore right and so the
smallest box that we could come up with
that still detects that object that must
be the bounding box for that object so
that's a fairly processing intensive
process to keep shifting over and over
and over and over and keep shrinking
that box so the less space that we have
to do that on the better so anyway I'm
gonna go with 800 by 450 and that's
still like a 16:9 aspect ratio and then
mmm this is actually already in numpy
format but I'm
going to say image underscore numpy
because we still want to convert this
because right now it's in it's in BGR
format so we're just going to say see me
to convert color now we're going to
cover at the color of screen to see B
two dots color is it c v2 dot invert
color C v2 dot color underscore BG are
to our GDP I think that's alright anyway
I'm just doing this to keep the naming
conventions I mean you can make this
better
this hey should it be called image on pi
really but anyway I'm just gonna stick
with that so after all this we can come
down here and like this was after the
viz util this is where we're gonna enter
new code so in fact this is probably
really small let me make this a little
bigger huge all right now so this is
what we've been writing good right here
anyway
coming back down here what we're gonna
do is do a CV to M show and we're just
going to show that window where's gonna
call it window basically and it's gonna
be CV to actually we've already resized
here so let's just show screen we don't
need to resize it again so shows screen
and then what we're going to do is the
if CV to wait key camelcase that 25 and
0 X F F equals Q that's a if statement
there we go Cigna to not destroy all
windows and break okay so that's all of
our code I'm pretty sure and now we're
ready to actually run and test that so
I'm gonna go ahead and boot up grand
theft auto and see if that works so I'm
gonna pause while I'm Putin up grand
theft auto so you don't have to sit
through that okay so it's actually
loading up you could probably eat in the
background but I don't I just know we're
in showing screen rather than image nope
I want to definitely change that
otherwise we wouldn't see anything
anyway pausing again as I load the game
some more maybe I can't get it to pause
all right so we've somehow detected a
bicycle there um but I'm gonna go ahead
and ignore that let's see if the other
menus have anything interesting and
we've got a television here probably I
think that says TV you can't tell it was
off screen anyway enough of that so
there we have some detection going on
right now we've got some people over
here well maybe a person we do have some
people over here but it also detected
these as people anyway there's some
people definitely over here getting some
framedrops I'm not sure how much longer
I'll be able to record this before we
die but yeah we've got some cars over
here I think it also should detect the
traffic lights yeah at least one of them
is detected kind of bouncing around
there but it does have the ability to
walk them these are sorry for my skype
these are pretty bad you know this
doesn't totally look like a traffic
light I almost wonder too if the code
I cannot pause this to save my life just
trying to mute my skype fine I'll do it
this way anyway
immature is just like his first time
recording because he's got Skype coming
anyway I kind of wonder cuz a lot of
this stuff if you if you change your
angle it detects it like helps the
detection like so I wonder if I was
viewing you straight on that would be
kind of silly to have object detection
for traffic lights at level with the
traffic light anyway
person in a motorcycle okay so that's
enough for now at least what you can see
that we've got it working and all that
in the next tutorial what we're gonna
actually do is we're going to Wow in a
vehicle man the frames are killing me
it's actually usually I don't get this
bad framerate I think it's because I'm
recording so hopefully hopefully the
recordings not totally horrible anyway
we're gonna actually go into a car and
detect other vehicles on the road and
then work on how do we calculate the
distance of other vehicles and then
after we end up doing that the next
thing basically for collision detection
and stuff like that our collision
avoidance hopefully after that but we're
gonna go ahead and do is since this is
Grand Theft Auto I figure we should
write some code to steal a car so so
that's all we're gonna be doing in the
coming videos if you have questions
comments concerns whatever up to this
point feel free to leave them below
hopefully you're getting decent frame
rates and hopefully you're not recording
at the same time but anyways pretty cool
it's pretty cool that GTA is realistic
enough that we can actually detect
things like I wonder if I if I load it
up like san andreas if it if it would
fit would detect remotely as well the
other thing I will say is I've made
custom bed I've made custom detectors
for grand theft auto like based purely
off grand theft auto data and it works
much better if you make a custom
detector but this law object detection
out of the box actually works pretty
well
and really does get better frames then
it's getting right now it's just because
I'm recording anyways
that's it questions comments leaving
below otherwise I'll see you in the next
video